[Music]
first of all thank you for joining me
again yeah great in seattle it's a
little rainier than last time but yeah
it's good this is more typical than this
time of year i believe it so last time
we chatted it was 2019. i feel like 2020
do you have any news resolutions or
things you focus on at the beginning of
a new decade uh well this year i'm going
to travel a little bit less than normal
the theme of the annual letter last year
which is why we spoke uh was surprises
and so i read the annual letter for 2020
and i'll link it below if anyone wants
to check it out but the theme was
swinging for the fences so how is that
different for you this year how does
that look as a strategy and as an
overall plan for you
well this annual letter we kind of took
the 20-year perspective uh because it's
our anniversary
we got going all the way back in the
year 2000 and had
you know uh dreams of having huge impact
in u.s education and global health
with global health because of some new
vaccines
that we've been involved with and those
have really gotten out
we
you know swung for the fences there and
actually
uh it succeeded education's been a lot
tougher where
uh although we've done some good
curriculum and done some things for
tutoring and kids getting feedback
you know we don't have uh the dropout
rate graduation preparedness still you
know the system is is not dramatically
improved and nowhere near as good as we
want it to be right i feel like you
always
seem to swing for the fences in general
it's just sort of a new way of framing
it but i have to ask if you are swinging
for the fences
what if you miss
well hopefully uh you get more than one
swing
either at the same problem like you know
multiple malaria vaccine constructs so
that you know if you have two or three
the combined chance of success is much
higher or
that you're working in multiple areas
not just one area right you know in
climate for example
i have a company that's uh trying to
make a nuclear reactor that would be
very cheap and that would have safety so
that the public
would be very accepting of it
now
you know even i realize that's high risk
you know less than 50 percent chance all
that comes together and yet
uh
if it did
and the only reason i'm involved is it
would really help with climate
let us generate electricity without any
greenhouse gases i have a quote from you
on climate um from the annual letter and
i think it's pretty good i read quotes
back to people from their own speeches a
lot but this is something you wrote
tackling climate change is going to
demand historic levels of global
cooperation
is that i guess one of the biggest
challenges of climate change and there's
always ways to innovate and tech and
innovate
in other fields but is the cooperation
of all these companies that all have to
chip in to make a difference one of the
biggest challenges yes the
getting to zero means
you know the all the countries going
along in all the different sectors of
the missions so it's not enough if you
just do passenger cars
uh even that's super hard
and very important but you also have to
do industrial and agriculture
and other forms of transport like
planes and
and long distance trucks and so
the number of innovations is very very
high
and in some of these areas the green
approach
will still cost more
than the dirty approach and so
convincing people that the benefits of
stopping these emissions
mean that you should be willing
to pay extra for some of these
activities
if we get super good innovation in a few
cases we might get the
the green premium i call it to zero so
that you you don't pay any extra but
because there's so many sorts of
emissions
some of them
uh
will be premium priced and yet
uh we have to go
to you know 194 countries and get almost
all of them particularly the big ones
yeah uh to go along or else the
motivation for the others you know falls
apart and the whole thing fails and on
that same theme you know the premium of
something that might be considered
better or cleaner for the environment we
spoke about tesla briefly last time and
i think what you've mentioned basically
was they have a great product but
they're still premium it's still more
expensive to get one which is why it's
it's not everywhere do you think that if
that problem is solved that could be one
of the the more important things towards
advancing an advent of sustainable
transport like that's one of the most
important things for that company and
eventually for the entire industry is to
bring the premium down to hopefully zero
so that it's a no-brainer to go electric
or zero emissions yeah the premium today
is
is there uh but over the next decade
except that the range will still be a
little bit less
that premium will come to zero so if we
take all the sectors
uh
passenger cars
is actually one of the most hopeful and
certainly
tesla uh if you had to name one company
that's helped drive that it's them now
all the car companies including some
other new ones
are moving super fast to do electric
cars actually you know the biggest
concern is will the consumers
uh get on board overcome their range
anxiety you know i just got a
porsche
uh ti cam which is an electric car okay
and i have to say i mean it's a premium
chrysler but yeah it is very very cool
uh
that that's my first uh electric car and
i'm enjoying it a lot yeah i have to
follow up on that because that's the car
i'm super curious about um you don't see
them nearly as much but when you see
pretty much everywhere is tesla model 3.
yes that's i see them all over seattle
you see them all over downtown and if
you're in la is there anything like
missing from that experience obviously
it's a fun car but other than getting
the price down and continuing to make a
better product is there any other reason
not to go electric i guess well the
range you know if you
want to go a long distance right uh the
pervasiveness of recharging the time to
recharge yeah you know compared to
filling up a tank of gas the amount of
energy that's going in you know per
minute of uh filling your gas tank it's
kind of mind blowing i mean gasoline is
very dense energy 30 times more dense
than the current lithium batteries
and now a factor of two improvement in
the range will get it so most people
it's you know only uh less than three
percent of car sales uh globally today
uh you know norway
uh is higher than that and china's uh
looks to be one of the marks that will
develop the most quickly so you know
price will
uh it's important for that to come down
the of course you spend a little bit
less on the electricity than you would
spend on gasoline and the maintenance
cost
uh
is a little bit less although the
insurance right now uh is a little bit
more premium cars
yeah and the repairs on you know like
these mirrors that are really rich and
complicated yeah you know fixing the
mirror used to be 100 bucks now it's
like 1500 so
uh
you know there's there's some work to be
done on a few of these areas but clearly
of all the climate areas i'd say that
one's the most hopeful for sure it's
away the future i say um all right so as
a youtuber i feel like i have to ask
about youtube and
you know with all the the work you've
done with not only spreading vaccines
for as many people as possible but
there's also kind of the second job of
spreading information about vaccines you
mentioned in the annual letter people
who are hundreds of meters from
somewhere where they could have gotten a
vaccine and didn't what do you think
about the role of sites like youtube
in the spread of not just information
but potentially misinformation when it
comes to things like vaccines or climate
change
yeah it's very tricky because
historically the newspapers or the
the media
were very responsible about
not letting
untruths about vaccine safety get out
there now you know you don't want to get
rid of the good thing which is that
anybody can publish that barriers to
entry the diversity of voices
is so phenomenal compared to to
traditional publishing right i feel like
and you have a bit of a youtube presence
so you're able to share information
about things uh through social media
it's kind of a social media age so i
feel like that ideally helps your cause
more than it hurts it yeah my audience
probably isn't uh deep with the vaccine
doubters
yeah you know i in a creative way
uh
trying to get positive messages to
uh
be interesting and we have work to do on
that you know i would have thought
using experts on scientific knowledge
that the
all the internet would just make it so
much easier to learn about things
uh and yet in some ways
you know people aren't seeking out
complex information particularly if it
disagrees
uh
with some preconceived notion that they
have so you know how can
social media
get out there and be a little bit of a
force for education particularly on
climate where without a consensus
we won't do the the hard things that
will
save things for the next generation so
we want to we want to push the
information that helps the most amount
of people to as many people as possible
that's one version of swinging for the
fences yeah and
you know activate people want to do more
than just you know make their salary
they want to be involved with the cause
and for a lot of people
some way of engaging either as a
consumer an advocate a donor
in climate change that i'm amazed at how
the interest level is going up i hope
it's not a cyclical thing i hope that's
kind of a permanent thing because the
the challenge requires you know decades
of it being a very top issue as opposed
to okay for three or four years that was
kind of interesting let's move on to
something else all right last question
and this is inspired by uh neil i patel
who has interviewed you before from the
verge which is just a total tech
question
as a person as busy as yourself when do
you do
email i
you know i do some on the phone i do a
lot i'm very pc centric person i sit at
my desk with a nice big surface screen
nice uh
and you know i
get in early to do email a lot at night
particularly if i get a long email
i'll mark it as unread and then that
night i'm going through
the last few days looking at what i've
marked as i'm ready to say okay that's
got an enclosure let's really go through
that give a thoughtful response to it i
do know if i over schedule myself
the symptom of that is i'm i'm starting
to fall behind on an email i'm not
super responsive and that you know that
can be
you know a bad thing uh
you know today i got mail about you know
this coronavirus outbreak and how you
know should the foundation step up and
do something i'm you know i'm glad i was
there to give a really quick yes
response definitely some things are
urgent and uh
but it it's a it's a gauge of
of am i imagining my schedule well that
people
feel like i'm a quick quick to reply i
try to be quick to reply but we can't
always be
thank you again for the time i
appreciate it yeah great to see you good
to see you again hopefully we do it
again sometime excellent